one of the biggest impediments to
getting things done
in the united states senate when you
have a majority
but not a 60-seat majority is to
filibuster
and the filibuster is a mechanism
through which even if you
only need 50 votes to pass something
you need 60 votes to end debate
on that very issue and move
to the vote and this is a mechanism that
allows a party
in the minority to indefinitely hold up
voting on legislation
and to obstruct and to do all of the
things that republicans led by mitch
mcconnell
love to do to democrats now democrats
could blow up the filibuster completely
this is called the nuclear option and
we've talked about it before
but it is a double-edged sword and it
could as i've
talked to you before about it could come
back to really bite democrats when
republicans are back
in the majority at some point in the
future this has been a point of
contention about which there are
reasonable positions on both sides
but in an interview with abc news that
aired last night
joe biden told george stephanopoulos he
does
support reforming the senate filibuster
not eliminating it with the nuclear
option but reforming it well what
exactly is the reform that joe biden
is interested in let's take a look at
the clip zach so aren't you going to
have to choose
i know you've been reluctant to do away
with the filibuster aren't you gonna
have to choose
between preserving the filibuster and
advancing your agenda
yes but here's the choice i don't think
you have to eliminate the filibuster you
have to
do it what it used to be when i first
got to the senate back in the old days
when you used to be around there and
that is that a filibuster you had to
stand up and command the floor
and you had to keep talking alone you
couldn't call for you know
they no no one could say you know quorum
call
once you stopped talking you lost that
and someone could move in and say
i moved the question of so you got to
work for the filibuster so you're for
that reform you're for bringing back the
talking filibuster i am
that's what it was supposed to be look i
think don't hold me to the numbers
george but i think between 1960 and 2000
they were like i'm making this number up
i don't know
there were like uh you know 50
filibusters and now they're like 200
since then
since then just put a hold on it that's
it yeah i mean you know so
the idea it almost is getting to the
point where
there's you know democracies having a
hard time functioning
a hard time functioning now this is
notable for a few reasons now just a
couple of days ago
joe biden's press secretary jen saki was
asked about the filibuster during a
press briefing
and she said joe biden does not want to
change any rules on the filibuster
so that seems to have changed but more
importantly on substance
biden doesn't say get rid of the
filibuster
just make it more difficult by requiring
an actual talking filibuster and
this is an important detail to
understand right now
senators can indefinitely extend debate
on a topic
and prevent voting on that topic by
asking
to extend debate period and just never
allowing debate to end when someone
moves to end debate and vote
republicans can say no i want to extend
debate and they're able to do it
in the past senators actually had to
hold the floor
and speak and keep speaking to delay
a bill and the idea that joe biden is
suggesting
and others have also mentioned is to
require the actual
speaking to take place so senators can't
just
ask for an extension and then another
one and then another one
they actually have to talk through the
filibuster and this would have two
effects
first of all it would require
republicans to actually
organize to have back to back-to-back
speakers in the senate
never-ending with their 50 senators they
actually
would be able to do it but how long will
they be willing to do it from a
practical standpoint
24-7 day after day after day
but maybe more importantly a talking
filibuster
that goes on and on and on merely to
prevent a vote
on an issue is going to pick up media
attention the longer it goes
and presumably it will come off as
exactly the type of blatant obstruction
that it is
now the possible political
miscalculation
is that we're assuming the current
republican party
would be mad about that and they would
say this must end let's just have a vote
but the current republican party has
been so propagandized
that they might not actually be that mad
about an endless talking filibuster they
might like it
but the gamble is that the left and the
centrists and maybe some republicans
would say guys we
we don't have control of the senate this
isn't really democratic
this has to end you have to put the
issue to a vote maybe that is what
what would happen i don't know now why
does this matter bigger picture
it matters because filibuster rules
in the next two years might actually
determine
does washington d.c become a state does
puerto rico become a state
does automatic voter registration get
passed
and a whole bunch of other important
issues this is not trivial and the point
is that right now
it's too easy to filibuster with very
little work and without much political
cost
now there's a couple of other ideas that
have been floated one i this this is not
what biden supports but these are other
ideas
to affect the filibuster without ending
it
one idea is you have to have 40
senators present to extend the
filibuster right now it's if you
don't have 60 you can't end debate
the idea is to flip the onus and put it
on republicans to keep having 40 of
their 50 senators
in the chamber 24 7 to continue
extending the filibuster
that would be a very good idea without
blowing it up
the other thing is that the talking
filibuster
it should have to be relevant to the
topic at hand in other words
if you are trying to end debate on
automatic voter registration
and go to a vote you can't get up there
and read a dr seuss book to filibuster
you should be filibustering materially
with something connected to automatic
voter registration
and that's another possibility that
could be done we will see
this is a really big deal and uh you
know it's one of these things where
a lot of this stuff like oh joe when is
joe biden going to do his first
press conference sort of like you know
it's an inside
the beltway story that also has very
little
impact on americans the filibuster is
something
a lot of people are not following and
aren't aware of
but it actually does relate to things
that would have a very direct and
serious impact
uh on americans in terms of what it
would allow the senate to do so we're
going to continue following now
this is this is joe biden's latest view
on this issue let's now talk about
the flip side of the coin which is mitch
mcconnell's view
on the issue one of our sponsors is
monk pack it's tough to get excited
about most granola bars they have a lot
of carbs
they don't taste that great they don't
really satisfy your cravings
but monk pack has something totally
different monk pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture
only 140 calories one gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs which
make them work
perfectly for the keto or low carb
lifestyles
they come in excellent flavors like
coconut cocoa chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla
that's my new favorite
i love these because you can just grab
them anytime maybe it's a quick
breakfast an afternoon snack when you're
busy
forget the dry bland granola bars you've
had in the past
try out monk pack keto granola bars
if you don't love them like i do they'll
give you all of your money back
you'll get 20 off when you go to
monkpack.com and use the coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video